this is a production of Cornell
University
I was gonna ask so it was really fun
Gillian said hey do you want to give a
seminar about what you did on sabbatical
and I thought wow that sounds pretty fun
so
um this is uh let's see
this is not you won't you can't read it
if you're in the room oh over there
the amazing research that uh past and
present
students postdoc staff have done in the
lab
this is not that seminar
that taking nothing away from their work
which is amazing uh but this is really a
seminar about what I've been doing for
the last year and the surprising things
I've learned and I think the importance
of going somewhere else and and
essentially walking in someone else's
shoes
yeah
so uh
I think we left Geneva my lab is on the
Geneva campus
um
and we left Geneva with a pickup truck a
dog a husband a U-Haul trailer that was
exclusively filled with toys bikes and
whatnot he's uh and then I drove my car
actually all the skis were on on top of
my car uh we left in August of 22 I
think we left about the 10th and it took
us two and a half days to drive across
the country and we landed in Fort
Collins Colorado which is an hour north
of Denver uh the home of Colorado State
University
I was hosted by the amazing Jan leech
who many of you know is a member of the
National Academy of Sciences and just a
remarkable person but we all thought it
was hilarious that she loved always
standing next to the biohazard sign
uh Jan until very recently was the
associate Dean for research in the
College of agricultural Sciences at
Colorado State
um and now she uh she stepped down from
that administrative role and is
continuing to run her lab as a
university distinguished professor
so I was in the department of as I said
agricultural biology uh which was which
was interesting on to describe the
department in a minute but the goals for
my sabbatical were to learn about the
department and the research I knew I
would be learning a lot about bacterial
plant interactions which interests me a
focus of Jan's research microbiome
research the impact of climate change
that was all
some of what happened again not what I'm
talking about today
uh to gain a better understanding of
disease issues in Colorado
to learn about I knew you know all of
the West is very dry so to learn about
Agriculture and in water limited areas
and to write some grants which again is
not the topic of today but I did write I
think I wrote nine grants
and some of them were awarded
[Laughter]
so in the department of agricultural
biology
alumnus Amy charkowski uh is the chair
she got her PhD with Alan Comer in The
Graduate field of Plant Pathology and
plant microbiology and Amy works on
bacterial diseases of potato so we've
known each other forever and it was
really fun interacting with Amy Amy is
actually transitioning out of chair of
the department and into the dean
associate dean of research role for the
college so
um Kudos saying
in the department of AG biology uh
the folks that are there the plant
Pathologists entomologists and weed
scientists with uh some portion of the
plant genetics faculty there as well
so in some respects it's like sips and
that groups that were previously
departments had been combined together
but in some respects very different
because the focus was really on Pest
Management whether it was Weeds
pathogens or insects so that was
interesting
uh the first thing you need to learn
when you go somewhere new is how do
these folks Network so there are 28 I'm
not even kidding 28 microbreweries
within the city of Fort Collins Colorado
which has 150 000 people
so pretty much every activity that was
not on campus was out of microbrewery
and you could go to a different one
every week
and let me also say that none of those
microbreweries Brew Light beer
so my idea of we're gonna go and
exercise and I'm going to lose 10 pounds
now
and the other thing is that um there's
so many group exercise activities and in
part that's because there's 300 days of
sun
and when people talk I mean they're like
oh what's the first thing you notice
there's a difference between Fort
Collins and and Ithaca and I'm like you
know it's really sunny here
um and they're like what what do you
mean
and you know we don't have 300 days of
sun
uh so there's always opportunities to
get together with groups of people uh
whether it's hiking in the in the winter
or or in the fall or the spring uh they
have a Four Mile Turkey Trot which the
entire department participates in
um and so there's just a lot of
activities that really surround out
being outside because the weather really
permits that
so when I was at Colorado State I was
asked to give a seminar where I did in
fact talk about the science that happens
in my lab and as some of you know uh
some of that science involves a pathogen
called phytophthora capsucci and to
research that pathogen we have a nine
Acre Farm and so I was talking about our
research and I was talking about this
farm and I said to the group at Colorado
State one of the things I really love
about this slide is that you can see the
drain tiles so this field is very wet
but to to enable us to grow crops on
this field but drain tiles are there
um and and you can really see them
clearly and uh Colorado actually one
thing I loved about the seminars in
Colorado was that people would just sort
of ask questions as you were talking and
uh both Jan and Amy are like hey Chris
why don't you explain drain tiles and
I'm confident that my face went
huh and Jan's like we don't have those
here
wow it was that moment mid-seminar of I
am no longer in New York
so I went on to explain that Geneva New
York has a drain tile Museum which
everybody thought was absolutely
hilarious
um and and the importance of drain tiles
to agriculture east of the Mississippi
so after that
conversations between students and and
whomever you know was always like so
really you guys want to take the water
away I'm like I we could not grow crops
if we did not take the water away and
and it just it it turned into this
incredible learning experience for me
well I had spent four years at UC Davis
when I was there you know I was working
on fruit trees and it was flood
irrigated and and the concept of of
where is the water coming from at that
time it it just wasn't part of our
conversation and so uh
a lot of the conversations
at in Colorado surround water and if you
were to so if you were to ask a grower
in New York what is their biggest issue
they're going to say labor a lot of our
crops are hand harvested labor is a huge
issue
every single grower or rancher in the
state of Colorado will say water
every single one
so again it was this really interesting
difference
uh so Fort Collins is here oh I should
use this having seen many a seminar on
Zoom uh Fort Collins is here
and uh Colorado State under its uh
agricultural experiment station has 10
research centers across the state of
Colorado
uh the closest one being about 40
minutes away
um and the and the furthest ones well
this is not the furthest by distance but
it took it takes about seven and a half
eight hours to get there
because you can't just go from there to
there
[Laughter]
um I'm not going to be talking about it
today but one of the really unique uh
things that Colorado state has recently
built is the spur campus which is uh
right in Denver and uh plant
Pathologists that some of you might know
Jim Burdine he was the former chair of
climatology at the University of
Minnesota is actually the dean of that
campus and uh it's really completely
geared toward getting the general public
engaged in agriculture and there's an
entire kitchen there's a sensory panel
there's a
hydroponic system and they really find
ways to bring the community in
additionally in Colorado
the largest sector of Agriculture is
cattle
the largest beef slaughterhouses are in
Colorado the largest and so much of the
plant agriculture
is associated with growing food for
cattle
so on the Eastern side of the state
over here well at least part of this
Eastern side what you'll see
predominantly is cattle and then Maize
and Alfalfa that are grown to feed the
cattle
so those are several interesting
interesting angles the first research
that Center that I went to uh was in the
San Luis Valley and
this is a fascinating Valley
um surrounded uh by mountains and I'll
have pictures of those mountains in a
second but right right down here because
the valley is so dry it's at 8 000 feet
and it's the highest in elevation of the
research centers and um the winds come
across from west to east and there's a
giant National Park called Sand Dunes
National Park which is an absolutely
fascinating place to visit
so I I first uh actually I didn't end up
getting to San Luis Valley until
maybe break April
and this is what the valley looked like
uh the research center is here the
valley is surrounded to the east by the
uh
so I'm ready to Crystal mountains and to
the west by the San Luis mountains so
it's really quite amazing when you're
standing looking in One Direction and
then you turn around and look the other
way
yeah
um the the soil is much uh much more
Gravelly on one side on the Eastern side
of the valley and less less Gravelly on
the western side
so what what did I do when I visited uh
the San Luis Valley
well I learned about quinoa you guys we
don't grow quinoa here
so quinoa is a crop that's um from the
High Altitude Andes and it grows really
well in the San Luis Valley of Colorado
and an entomologist friend of mine uh
Ada chapaniak
it's really easy to say but it looks
hard
um she has a project there's a stem
boring insect that will bore into the
stem of the quinoa plants cause the stem
to collapse and and Growers will lose
yield so I went up with I went up with
her when they were planting one of their
quinoa trials and I met several of the
quinoa Growers who were absolutely
amazing they have a product Colorado
quinoa that is branded
um
and I learned also that there are
different colors of quinoa seed I was
not a quinoa Aficionado and the white
quinoa is the highest value so in case
you're at the store wondering if why
white quinoa costs more than red or
brown
and I asked if it tastes different and
it was great you can tell when you're
not you know you're not versed in a crop
because I'm like oh well does it taste
different and
all four of these folks looked at me and
were like well no
but as I was traveling with otta
um she's like you know there's some kind
of mildew disease of quinoa that's a
real problem and I'm like I work on
Builders
uh and in fact in many locations Downey
mildew caused by paranoster variabilis
is the limiting factor to quinoa
production on the right hand side of the
slide this is one of Otto's field trials
uh quinoa is planted very close together
and it requires very little water even
to germinate uh so on the left hand side
I did all this research on Downey mildew
and um so then we went out there I'm
like so you know do you guys ever see
Downey mildew and they're like
again that was we get eight inches of
precipitation annually in the San Luis
Valley and then you know they're like do
you think we get down in building I'm
like no
so Downey mildew is a water mole that
really thrives in wet and high humidity
environments the humidity here is you
know probably about 12 percent and as I
said they get eight inches of
precipitation
all of their irrigation comes from
groundwater aquifers they get I'll show
in a minute but they get diverted water
from the Rio Grande
or the Arkansas Rivers the Colorado is
the Headwater of eight major river
systems and so they get they get water
uh through irrigation ditches
um
but they use that water to soak into the
ground to replenish the aquifer then
everything in the valley is um
irrigated from from groundwater potatoes
are the among the largest commodity
crops in the San Luis Valley and
especially seed potatoes which
um you're going to want to grow in an
area that's very isolated so you don't
get pathogens that could be transmitted
into those seed potatoes and so the San
Luis Valley is a really important seed
potato production area as well also
irrigated
the other thing we went uh to the San
Luis Valley for
us to look at hemp so this is a field of
hemp that had just been harvested
um the hemp this hemp was harvested uh
there's maybe that's maybe uh what three
inch orange stubble on the ground and
then the stems lay in the ground reading
so these stems here uh are all ready
during the season uh this would have
been irrigated it's a crop circle it
would have been irrigated using pivot
irrigation uh most of the pivot
irrigation circles in the San Luis
Valley are 220 Acres so there's a center
pivot that's metered you only get a
certain amount of water and then that
the this was really fascinating the
irrigation technology is such that the
sprinklers that come down from the pivot
irrigation uh move depending on the
height of the crop to ensure that you
get maximum water to the soil rather
than losing it to the air
so uh here at Cornell we also have a
hemp program and it was really fun to
visit there because we were in the
process of purchasing what's called a
decorticator
from formation AG which is in the San
Luis Valley so a decorticator is a
machine that basically smashes the hemp
stems and it separates the fast fibers
which are on the outside of the hemp
from the really hard herd fibers on the
inside of the house
um and you can see this is a
decorticator in action here
and
um this is what extremely clean outer
fibers look like the outer fibers can be
used
um well sometimes they're used in things
like uh
installations but they can also be used
for fabrics and then the inner herd is
used as animal bedding so all of the
hemp uh in the fiber production is um is
used and so we got to see that whole
process so just yesterday this is hot
off the press uh Corbett who I showed in
this earlier slide that's Corbett
ketoformation AG Corbett drove
Cornell's new hemp decorticator from the
San Luis Valley in Colorado to Geneva
New York for our hemp field day tomorrow
so
um you can see here that uh he actually
he he brought a bale of of uh hemp stems
because he honestly didn't trust that we
would have like the proper bail to show
everyone how well it worked
um uh so this is the bail unwinder and
then the hemp stems will go into this
which is the um the corticator which
will smash it up then uh it moves into
this machine where
the the longest fast fibers are
separated out uh this is the control
panel for the entire thing then you move
over here and what you're actually doing
on on this side of the decortication
process is separating the inner herd
pieces into different sizes because
different sizes will be used for
different products so our decorticator
is on a trailer so Ag and Department of
vegan markets in New York hopes that
Cornell will pull this trailer around
the state and show the promise of using
hemp for fiber in rotation with other
field crops so that was that was a
really fun connection
please so how expensive is such a
machine
uh four hundred thousand dollars
so is the idea for a program that
they've got to collectivize
yeah so yeah well ideally we there would
be enough interesting Growers that
processors would move into the state
and so there would be a processing
facility within 50 miles and then people
would bring their Bales drop them there
and they would be processed as if it
were great
but then the processors don't want to
come unless they know they're going to
have enough Growers and The Growers
don't want to grow unless they know they
can sell it
right so Susan's question was is most
hemp production for fiber or is it for
other things uh for four years ago it
would have been predominantly for the
CBD Market which has completely crashed
and so right now there's actually very
little hemp grown particularly with uh
high THC cannabis Market coming online
but there is a lot of interest in fiber
and Grain and and some of the hemp you
can actually Harvest uh both the grain
that could potentially be fed to animals
as well as the fiber
so uh one uh of the amazing things that
I got to do was uh Jan leech and Amy
charkowski teach a course called
Colorado egg systems and in that course
you visit each of the 10 research
centers across the state
and I learned an incredible amount
while riding on let me tell you Colorado
state has really nice buses in their
Fleet
and Wi-Fi was great so the course was
um composed of graduate students
from across campus uh upper level
undergrads the and and then faculty that
were interested the chair of
um chemical engineering came along
mechanical engineering because so much
of the focus is on irrigation technology
and agricults both of which are really
taking off in Colorado that engineering
is going to be a key component of that
moving forward
and visitors are are allowed to come
along as well and I'm just throwing this
out there to tell people I would love to
figure out how we could have this class
here
it was so it was a great cohort building
experience for the students on the bus
and and you know you're on the bus so
long that at some point everybody ends
up getting to know everyone else and it
um it was really amazing the other thing
that I hadn't really thought about
before we started visiting each of these
centers is how important it was to the
faculty and staff that were at these
centers to have the students and you
know folks from Fort Collins come and
visit there and show interest and and
realize the importance of the work that
each of those places are doing so so
that was really cool
and let me say it's extremely expensive
at Colorado State uh they spend 25 000
they got fifteen thousand dollars from
the college and ten thousand dollars in
the University
what do you think our chances are guys
but yeah
yeah
I mean I think I think it's that same
concept of where is agriculture moving
in the future what what do we need and
it's absolutely connected to Workforce
Development
Gillian Oh I thought you were going to
chime in with a ten thousand dollar wrap
[Laughter]
uh so this was also really really
interesting to me so as I mentioned
earlier in eastern Colorado it's about
cattle and I had never I I guess I
probably should have but in my life I
had never visited a research facility
that was really focused on animal
research
um that we tend to segregate plant
research and animal research and
learning about the
the ways in which you do cattle research
you have to have you know identical
genetics across fairly large groups of
cattle to get the numbers you need to do
the statistics
um and how do they do that how do they
decide what goes into the feed so in
this particular study they were studying
uh methane responses in cattle the
amount of methane that was produced
predominantly through burping which is
the the greatest
methane producer depending on the
different feed and so learning about
that was really fascinating and a person
who is completely integrated with the
research is Temple Grandin and many of
you may have heard of her because of her
work
um a
highlighting that uh neurodiverse people
and autistic people can very much
contribute to the greater good as well
as uh she designed cattle shoots so that
as cattle were going to be slaughtered
or to be moved from one location to an
to another it would keep the anxiety
level lower
so uh animal
husbandry really and um she said it was
it was really interesting to meet her
uh I'm not going to talk about each of
the stations
um but one that I do want to highlight
is called the Plainsman Research Center
and just below this is the panhandle of
Oklahoma
and just to this side is Kansas
so you're
20 miles from one and 15 miles from the
other
and that it was part of the Dust Bowl
in that whole area of Oklahoma this
corner of Colorado was part of the Dust
Bowl and and I had I had never visited
an area that that had
soil and as as everyone said what what
we currently choose to call soil that
was anything similar to this
so uh
I uh I had never been in a place where I
could see that far to the Horizon which
was also really really amazing and it
seemed uh in some of the pictures that I
show you'll see it it seemed windy and I
was like wow it's really windy here and
they're like
this is a normal day
so
one in three years
growers in this area will get a crop
and if they get a crop one in three
years they're happy
The Growers in the area CSU was going to
close this Research Center and The
Growers in the area actually put in
money to keep that research area going
because they feel it's so critical to
their survival which again was really
really interesting
uh this trip was in the end of May and
you'll see that there's not a lot of
green here
it was it was a rough spring so
um some of the some of the things that I
learned they had a trial that was it was
really interesting
they looked at they're looking at and
continue over several many years to look
at
the height at which corn is is combined
because and to try to determine if you
know what what height can you still get
a decent yield of the Maize and have a
larger stock to prevent the soil that
you have from blowing across the Great
plants that was really interesting and
you can't see it very well here
um but these are actually little tiny
sand dunes in the middle of a field that
have come their waves the field should
be flat the field was plowed flat but
because soil had blown into that area
and so this particular field this was a
new assembly I've told this story to
some of you but
um the the manager of the farm it's like
yeah
this field here where you can see a
little bit of green wheat coming up yeah
you know that field you know it seemed
we had the right amount of corn around
it to protect the seed
but this field blew
and the field the the seed just blew
away
uh right and he's like yeah this field
is a real problem it's blown three years
in a row wow it was it was absolutely
fascinating and he said you know that
for for being here that's part of what's
expected but you know that those are the
kinds of things that we really want to
work on the other thing that was very
interesting about this location was that
the state of Colorado is in some places
paying Farmers to put the land back into
native Buffalo grasses
um which have a a broader root system
that hopefully could stabilize the soil
so so we learned a lot about that which
was also very interesting
and this is my picture of the soil at
the Plainsman Research Center
so it goes from mud to cracked concrete
they tell us
it's really it was just remarkable to to
see that and and really to think about
what you know the people were trying to
live through in the Dust Bowl it's just
incredible and the other thing I'll say
is that um that that Southeastern corner
of Colorado is really very poverty
stricken Colorado is booming generally
as a state yeah I think every person we
met had some connection to New York or
California like the coasts are moving to
Colorado but this part of the state is
very impoverished and the reason is
because there is no water
okay
so this was new to me I I saw after we
went to Plainsman we went to uh what's
called a diversion head and
um here
is the Rio Grande
and starting right there
part of a portion of the water gets
diverted and comes off to go into
irrigation canals
and this happens hundreds of times along
the Colorado the Rio Grande the Arkansas
the Republican Rivers so this is it
looks when you look at it it looks like
a river but it's the head of the
irrigation ditch
and so this was absolutely fascinating
to me uh the Water laws and regulations
that we learned about are amazing and
many of the laws are from when there was
a gold rush in the 1800s and those laws
are still in place and essentially the
first people that asked for water rights
are the people that get the most water
even today
and uh there there is a list of hundreds
of thousands of people that want water
rights and there's simply not enough
water
so that was interesting water rights are
private property also interesting
um and those diversion gates are owned
by companies which surprised me I
thought it would be a public Venture
um but they're owned by several
different companies uh and they're
called ditch companies
and um
ditch companies manage all of the
surface water irrigation systems across
the state and they have people who
there's a job called a ditch Rider
and the ditch Rider originally would
have ridden a horse but now
predominantly actually rides motorcycles
um to maintain the ditch to and really
they're the ditch police
right nobody can take water from the
ditch which would be a real problem
um and they're armed
so because water is so scarce
um the ditch Riders have a very a very
serious job they calculate water volumes
which is also interesting how water
volumes are calculated and they can
enter private property without any
permissions so if an irrigation ditch
which several folks on the bus said this
they have irrigation ditches that run
through their property
uh the ditch Riders just come on and to
check the ditch make sure you're not
stealing water make sure you know
it is what where the maintenance is what
it needs to be so I thought that was uh
for me that was just something very
different than than any anything I'd see
a parent in New York
uh almost done so the other side of
Colorado uh is also very fascinating
because there is more water and that's
really
um that's really the the difference and
Western Colorado is where they grow
fruit the the land is extremely Rocky
and so it's not prime AG land but there
is water and um there are there are
fruit trees uh peaches are probably the
largest uh in production area but
there's also pears cherries and they're
they're trying to develop a grape
industry
which is really tough because they can
have really cold winter Winters and
really hot summers
I did see some disease uh
cytos for a canker which is caused by
several different species uh within the
fungal genus site phosphora is a huge
issue on Peach especially when the
winters get really cold
um the the trunks will crack because of
the cold and then heating up with the
bright Sun 300 days of sun and that
allows cytos for a camper to get into
the trees so I felt like I had a show
and the other interesting thing
um is that they have a large program
about phylloxer and grape so this sign
right here says stop we have phyloxera
on this field
um we don't want to spread it across the
state know that so uh I thought it was
interesting that um they're they're
really they're focusing not only on how
do we produce the grapes but
you know phenox or which has been in
soils in most places like our grapes in
the world for you know 100 years isn't
is new to Colorado which is just
um so the unique research uh that we
were able to see they have an entire
facility for irrigation technology as I
said agrovoltaics or or having solar
panels over agricultural Fields is as a
huge and booming area
um they are trying to bring in new crops
one of the most the most the the crop
that will bring the most Growers the
most money is alfalfa
and Alfalfa is a fairly high water using
crop so in that there are Growers that
grow Alfalfa in the San Luis Valley
where there's eight inches average of
precipitation a year and Alfalfa takes
about 20.
so um it's it's not a good match so
they're looking for new crops Workforce
Development is very high
um at on the priority list of all of
these research centers they're bringing
in students they're bringing in you know
um uh farmers and and helping with
successional planning and that was
really interesting and they're trying to
to build or or I guess I would say
rebuild relationships with indigenous
communities in the state
so in addition to uh learning a lot
about AG in Colorado we of course met
amazing people
um and we got to see a lot of uh amazing
sites in the state
we also got to enjoy the natural beauty
of Colorado so we we saw so many elk you
guys there and they're like so big
they're everywhere
um this is a this is a very uh uh it's a
female actually of a bighorn sheep
so we saw males as well but I didn't get
a very good picture lots of antelope
which I found impossible to take a photo
of
um mule deer they don't have
white-tailed deer they have mule deer
which are larger uh and bison so these
are all bison including blonde bison uh
this just reminded me of the song You
Know Home on the Range right
so these fast Open Spaces
um the flowers uh so I guess
so much different flora and fauna which
I expected but when you see it it just
makes you happy
um and then uh and then the hiking you
know whether it was in state parks there
are a really excellent system of state
parks or um uh the national parks real
more standing
and then thanks to everyone in sips who
helped buy me an epic pass so an Epic
Pass enables you to ski I think at 10
different uh Ski locations
um across the state and we we made
excellent use of the Epic Pass let me
say
um it was it was absolutely fantastic
and even when you know the weather
wasn't great we still had a blast it was
really wonderful
um thanks to my lab
that which you know it didn't crumble
and collapse they kept it running while
I'm away I have this fear that they're
like oh is she gonna leave again soon
but they really kept everything running
but what happened to be home I can't
tell you guys how I was not expecting
this so happy to see that the plant
science building was finally under
renovation that took years off my life
you guys so it was really excited to see
um and as Libby said I will be starting
as director of Cornell agritech in
Geneva on October 1st
and this actually is a picture of Fort
Collins from
the top of a hike that we did quite a
few times at a state park that you can
look over this is a reservoir Horsetooth
Reservoir not a sport calls with that
I'll answer any questions
uh so Marvin asked what crops they were
growing under the solar panels
um
they were uh they're at one of the
research stations they were looking at
Alfalfa and Maize and barley Coors
actually tries to buy as much barley as
they can from growers in the state
um they they were looking at the solar
panels that were that were mobile so
it's not like you had complete shading
of the Sun and then when we were in in
the on the west side of the state
um they're act they were in the process
of building uh Edgar agar voltaics over
apples
which is really interesting
how many of the stations across the
state have students
uh how many of the stations across the
state have students so all of the
stations have projects where students
from campus will go there and and you
know have part of their research there
but and and most of them have places
where the students can stay while
they're there but none of them have
permanent full-time
students at the station
um
on the east side of the Colorado there's
like a bunch of planners just fine
your house like building like
yeah so the question was on in eastern
Colorado is there is there any
development of like a controlled
environment AG uh industry
um and to be honest everywhere that we
saw controlled environment AG industry
um it was for cannabis
and and I I didn't really hear a lot of
talk about we we did on the western side
of the state we saw a facility an
aquaponic facility where they're growing
uh both tilapia and lettuce um but not
as much on the Eastern side of the state
most of the water is going into new
housing developments
all right how prevalent was enrollment
uh in the Department of Natural
Resources uh buffalo grass initiative
and uh at least from what we were told
initially there was a lot of enrollment
but then people would enroll in the
program and then decide they wanted a
farm again so that became tricky
um and especially as the soil started to
stabilize they would think oh well you
know now can I plow this in and farm
again and so
um they're actually the the Colorado
Department of Natural Resources taking a
new tactic
um to try to again expand the program so
I think it's there are some Farmers but
it's not hugely prevalent
one of the things that everyone asks is
you know what did you miss and of course
the people and but man we missed sweet
corn
it's so it's not very humid there and so
you just don't get that juicy sweet corn
that so like the day we got back we went
to a farmers market
my understanding of uh I guess the mood
in Upstate New York about
converting land to have solar panels or
maybe acropologetics I don't know is
that farmers are not interested in
switching Landover uh
going to Colorado I'm curious the
drivers are for people and being
interested in searching designs
right so the question is what's the
driver and interest for agrimal tax and
let me say that in Colorado the majority
there there are huge solar fields and in
part because of the amount of sun but
right in in the in the public there's
not there's not a lot of agricults but
at research stations the hope is that um
you know they they can show successful
Harvest no decline no economic decline
plus enhancing energy also they're also
down near that Plainsman station vast
um uh wind turbine Fields
um and I think the same will be true
here in New York I mean um you know
there are there are uh research
Endeavors to see how well agrovoltaics
could work here as well and I think that
as Growers can see oh this is going to
work or this isn't going to work that's
going to help them make that decision
is
yeah yeah so the travel course I'm glad
you're interested Barbara I'm going to
be trying to Wrangle Wrangle folks in
um yeah so it's it's for credit but it
actually happens right after the spring
semester ends so it was like
um May 15th until June 7th and you went
to those places over the course of
three-ish weeks
um
the students enroll they get credit
there are there were assignments that
they had to do
um and and I don't think it was too
taxing they seem to enjoy it they were
reading some uh and there weren't the
you know the instructors were always
hoping that there would be more students
uh in the course than there were but
given the time of year a lot of students
that have field projects want to be out
getting things planted in the ground and
so they were trying to figure out that
balance of timing versus not for us that
timing would be tough because then yeah
that summer tuition and yeah but but I
feel like we could figure out how to
make it work and particularly if we
could find a campus-wide angle I think
that would be that would be really that
would be really fun
I have to do it in New York state and a
couple of shorter of that yeah because
in digital life right now we're doing
field trips like we were just a Geneva
last week and we all specific large bars
and then you know I think the
conversation between the research
component of Cornell and the actual
grower experience brings to explore into
contact with and helps I think develop
among the students a lot of the students
are that sells for Farms so they want to
see it
yeah and that's exactly how this worked
I think there were five or six different
trips yeah
because if you don't do it during the
semester the undergrads
of it exactly but the value is
quite a few engineers
for representation so it's not
it's a lot of really good interactions
the Q a always on site is dynamic
because the students from these
different backgrounds that's really
interesting questions that Maybe
yeah for sure and um I know we have to
go again
but uh I will say that
um you know I talked to the folks in
Colorado about if we could get this
established it would be fantastic to
have some of our students have the
opportunity to go and take the course in
Colorado and some folks from Colorado to
come here because it's just so different
I mean you know that and there you know
I'm telling the students about yeah we
have this station in Long Island and
they're like aren't there a lot of
people I'm like yes so so I think I
think building those bridges between
such different
um agricultural systems would be really
really fun
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu